hey everybody is Charlie so a lot of
people were asking me more about war
gang in the start so I thought I'd do a
little bit of an explainer about what
working is how it's different from
greensight I don't want to talk too much
about green site yet just because we're
gonna see a lot of that with bran in
season 6 so it could get a little
spoilery but I do think we'll see some
other Starks war game before the end of
the series so what I'm gonna do is talk
a little bit about things that George R
Martin has said about the stark children
publicly so I don't really consider them
spoilery but I will say general spoiler
warning for everything that's happened
on the show so far and new round of the
giveaway starts now - so all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video leave all your
wolf dream comments so here we go a
couple years ago George R Martin was
asked about the star children and wolf
dreams now when we say wolf dreams we're
talking about stark children in the
books that have previously dreamt that
they lived as wolves running around
hunting things
the thing is though is that most of this
is experienced through brands character
and we already know he's a warg and a
greenseer to boot so that's not really a
revelation but because all the star
children at one point had been bonded to
their dire wolves someone asked George R
Martin if they all had wolf dreams all
the stark children and he said yes they
did but just to clarify the only Starks
that have wolf dreams are the starts
with dire wolves that are still alive so
Sansa for instance probably doesn't have
wolf dreams because lady is dead on top
of that Rob also not gonna have any wolf
dreams because he himself is totally
dead along with gray wind but just
knocking brain off the list there's Jon
Snow with ghost
obviously Jon Snow is kind of hanging in
the lurch right now this is arya with
Nymeria and then there's a Rickon and
shaggy-dog so as of right now not
including bran because because he's a
total green seer all the Starks are
probably having wolf dreams without
realizing it and when I say not
realizing it they probably don't
understand exactly what's going on like
they don't know about working bran and
Jon Snow are the only two that have
gotten explainers about how working and
skin changing works and just to be clear
technically it's called skin changing
working is just when you skin change
with a dog or a wolf in the hierarchy of
skin changing those are like the bottom
of the barrel though the easiest most
people who are skin changers never get
above that level very mere six skins was
one of the few that we've seen so far
that was really good at it and even he
wasn't able to skin change into
something more diff
and a bird dogs and wolves of the
easiest birds are a little bit harder
and people are nearly impossible bran is
the first recorded instance in the books
anywhere in the books of anyone that
skin changed into another human but all
the stark children being Ward's that's
actually a pretty big deal that's pretty
cool does that mean we're gonna see them
all working into their dire wolves at
some point probably not
Sansa for instance even though lady is
dead and she's not having wolf dreams
that doesn't make her not a wart that
doesn't take away her warding ability
but turning into a skin-changer doesn't
really seem like it's where her
character is headed I'd really like to
see her take back control of Winterfell
and live a more traditional life just
rule the north but what about Jon Snow
if he's coming back why wouldn't he go
back and take control of Winterfell he
has sad something of a leadership part
learning to be an effective leader of
people who hate you but he's more of a
military leader in Winterfell even
though it's his home doesn't really feel
like his home he's one of those bastard
children that doesn't feel like they
have a true home if there's anything
that Catelyn Stark should regret it's
the way she treated Jon Snow growing up
she totally drank the kool-aid and
thought that Ned cheated on her and took
it as an affront and kept Jon Snow at
arm's length so I think if any stark
feels like Winterfell is their home that
they belong there it would be Sansa not
Jon Snow or even Arya for that matter
she doesn't want to be a lady but I do
think there's a high likelihood we could
see Jon Snow and REO work at some point
not in the powerful way that bran does
it just on a very low level just forget
about the fact that Jon Snow's body is
lying cold in the snow up to this point
his relationship with ghost is a lot
like Daenerys his relationship with her
dragons and if you're wondering no
dragon bonding and skin changing are two
completely different things I've already
mentioned Nymeria in the direwolf super
pack so you guys can let me know do you
think when arya gets around to coming
back to Westeros she will warg into
Nymeria and control the super pack that
might sound a little ridiculous but
she's not gonna stop having wolf dreams
so she still has a deep connection to
nymeria anyway so even if she doesn't do
something really crazy she'll still be
connected to nymeria in the same way
that Daenerys is connected to her
dragons like Daenerys can control her
dragons to a certain extent I'm sure
arya could do the same thing with
Nymeria it's just that arya is on this
faceless men ninja arc where she's
learning to use all these different
tools learn to use her body
so it stands to reason that she would
learn to use the other skills that she
already has it's just that she doesn't
understand that she has that ability
right now she knows she has wolf dreams
but she doesn't understand skin changing
and yes I've totally seen the spoilery
pictures from from the set from Game of
Thrones Ahri has been filming a ton of
faceless men scenes if you've read the
Mersey chapter from winds of winter the
chapter that George R Martin posted
he'll probably end up doing that for
those that are wondering how the Starks
became wargs in the first place like
it's something that's passed down
genetically so anyone that is born of
stark blood will at least have a limited
ability to work obviously bran is a
special case and that he was born a
Korean seer to most historical events
associated with skinchangers go back to
the first men so at some point they
developed that ability in the Starks
obviously the kings of winter descended
from the first men so they just got it
that way it's like trying to figure out
how the ancient Valerians developed
dragon bonding a little bit of blood
magic a little bit of genetic tampering
over a very long period of time but if
you're looking to debunk any crazy
theories I think the fact that Daenerys
is not a wart doesn't have any warga
bilities is good evidence that she is
not the daughter of Lyanna stark a lot
of people just ask me about the the
Rhaegar Targaryen Lyanna Stark Daenerys
theory like instead of Jon Snow being
their son is Daenerys their daughter so
now anyone born of that Union would have
limited working ability which Jon Snow
does have but you guys can let me know
do you want to see the other stark
children like do you want to see Rickon
whenever he comes back do you want to
see him warg into shaggy-dog it seems
like he might be coming back in season
six in a small way I don't know how big
a storyline they would give him but OSHA
was seen on set the actors that plays
OSHA so if she's coming back that prime
means that richens coming back to just
speaking of the TV show one of the
reasons I think we haven't seen a lot of
other working outside a brand's
storyline is because they want more
visual diversity with the arcs that they
give to the characters but even if they
don't show it on screen all the stark
children are skinchangers it's just that
only one of them is a good skin-changer
so what's gonna happen next because
Walking Dead is on break this week I'm
gonna post my Game of Thrones Q&A
tomorrow just like normal and for my
next bonus video just leave any requests
that you guys want anything you guys
want me to talk about there's been a lot
of Star Wars stuff going on they just
released a new Star Wars book that's
part of the expanding can't a part of
the new movie canon
it's called Star Wars aftermath so even
if you don't like to read check out the
audiobook it's a lot of fun it's pretty
good so far
it's all about what happens to the
Empire after the Battle of Endor in a
couple weeks they're actually releasing
the new Dunkin egg book what's really
just like the collected edition of the
old Dunkin eggs stories but I'll be
giving away a couple copies so look out
for that so just in case you guys
haven't seen there's a bunch of trailers
for TV shows that are coming back real
soon if you haven't seen any of them you
can click here this agents of shield
arrow season 4 a bunch of other stuff
doctor who's coming back and you can
click here to learn all about
cleganebowl and the gravedigger theory
and why everyone thinks that the hound
might be coming back thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you